the the the opening section
is called the way of discipline people
look for the shortcut the hack
and if you came here looking for that
you won't find it
the shortcut is a lie the hack doesn't
get you there and if you want to take
the easy road it won't take you where
you want to be
stronger smarter faster healthier
better free to reach goals and overcome
obstacles and be the best version of you
possible
will not happen by itself
it will not happen cutting corners
taking shortcuts
or looking for the easy way there is no
easy way
there is only hard work late nights
early mornings
practice rehearsal repetition study
sweat
blood toil frustration and
discipline
discipline there must be discipline
discipline the root of all good
qualities
the driver of daily execution the core
principle that overcomes
laziness and lethargy and excuses
discipline defeats the infinite excuses
that say
not today not now i need a rest
i will do it tomorrow
what's the hack how do you become
stronger smarter faster healthier
how do you become better how do you
achieve true freedom there is only
one way the way
of discipline
so that's the opening of the book
you know this is not there's not a bun
it's not a verbose book
you don't get paid by the word
like the old newspaper writers they used
to get paid by the word i'm not getting
paid by the word
trying to say what i'm trying to say
that's it
so so that that is from the first
section of this book and the first
section of this book is called
thoughts and then the second section is
called
actions and the action sections
includes three parts one is fuel
one is one is repair and maintenance
and one is the workouts so
let me give you some more of these
thoughts
[Music]
this one's called overcoming
procrastination
when and where to start
people want to know how to stop laziness
they want to know how to stop
procrastination
they have an idea in their head maybe
even a vision
but they don't know where to start so
they ask and they say where do i start
when is the best time to start and i
have a simple answer here
and now
that's it you want to improve you want
to get better
you want to get on a workout program or
a clean diet or start a new business you
want to write a book or
make a movie or build a house or a
computer or an app
where do you start you start right here
when do you start you start right now
you initiate action you go
here is the reality the idea isn't going
to execute itself
that book isn't going to write itself
those weights out in the gym
they aren't going to move themselves you
have to do it
and you have to do it now
so stop thinking about it stop dreaming
about it stop
researching every aspect of it and
reading all about it and debating the
pros and cons of it
start doing it
take that first step and make it happen
get after it
here and now
you've been kind of getting after it
lately haven't you yes sir
you made a goal you were telling me you
have goals
is this when's this is this kind of a
new uh
i think it's it was a progressive kind
of thing it started with
kind of certain things you know remember
i told you i got a
not a journal but a what do you call
like a planner yeah you got the day
planner yeah and i've tried the planner
thing many times
but not like the one that you actually
write in with a pencil
okay you know the kind like online i got
my digital my phone you know
yeah it's a weird thing there's a weird
thing that happens when you go
physical uh i agree yes for me that was
the case for sure
because some people that's how like if
you go did they got their cool app
organizer app whatever and it works
apparently
you know a lot of people use it so you
know you can't kind of can't refute that
yeah
but it didn't work for me like it didn't
stick at all
many many times you know i even did on
my computer
where i was like oh then i'm gonna leave
it on the desktop so i can always see it
but
it's still like it worked for certain
things but not for like
not like making a bunch of videos for
this well
but it was stuff that i would always
have to revisit mentally you know and
i'd be like okay it's open okay there it
is there it is there
but no yeah not for playing so i got a
planner and a pencil
a special pencil for the planner oh
mechanical pencil
yep i'm a big mechanical pencil guy yeah
because you can write
you can write super small if you need to
like man yeah it's good
and then you can erase or whatever
anyway so it started with that like
months ago almost a year really
and and that helped it's interesting as
i read this book
you know right now and as i was
reviewing it i was thinking about you
because you've been kind of like almost
involuntarily put on the path i guess
like i mean you've just been over
exposed i mean just there's no way for
you to kind of not
i mean you're sitting here for hundreds
and hundreds of hours yeah
so your life has transformed in many
ways yes
yeah big time it's funny okay here's a
quick story not deviate too much but i'm
gonna
so my daughter she's the kind like
she likes certain things and then
certain things she just straight up
doesn't like so
you make her start running laps hard she
don't like that kind of stuff
so we took her um you know it was it was
my nephew son we took
him to a running coach
and he and this coach has a group of
kids all varying levels
all the way up until like guys getting
full ride scholarships to like
oregon for lacrosse like the like high
level athlete is he a good runner
who the coach no who oh jace
yeah um we don't know that's the thing
we don't know so we
you know and he had some friends in
there and stuff like that so they were
like hey come
see this coach and all this stuff former
marine by the way
older guy and uh and there's a bunch of
kids there
and they're all doing their thing so i'm
like yeah let's throw my daughter in
there too she's seven
but young kid you know and there are a
couple of other young boys in there
eight-ish you know and i'm like she's
not gonna like this if this is hard
conditioning like track practice
which it was by the way um
it's it's she's not gonna like this
stuff she's gonna be whatever and she
did start crying at one point but she
did everything that's the thing okay so
the point is how i
wound up on the path even though i gotta
admit like i've always wanted to like
improve but let's face it i gotta go
with the wave man
and uh and sometimes beneficial some and
a lot of times not for sure but
i watched her and she was nervous she
was not used to this kind like intensity
you know and this guy is he the coach
he's really cool man he's he's but he's
not mellow
he's making jokes he's putting you down
all jokes you can totally tell but
you know she didn't know what to make of
that and so but
meanwhile all the kids are listening so
he's like go
run now you know this guy and the kids
are just going so she has kind of no
choice but to follow the wave
you know if it was me and her by herself
at any given moment she'll be like wait
i don't want to do that i want to do
this
yeah but when everyone else is doing it
her whole it at that moment
environment is just react or moving
right
you get caught up in that wave it's kind
of interesting because you you you use
the same
metaphor for both
for for two opposite things you said
well you know i i want to get better but
you know sometimes just kind of
go with the wave right exactly and now
all of a sudden you're saying that in
this situation
depending on the direction of the wave
if the wave's going in a good direction
you kind of get caught in that
that's what i feel like you you know you
hanging out with me
for the last five years by the way of
just the podcast because we've been
hanging out for a lot longer than that
and look let's face it you had a lot of
elements of
of discipline and hard work i mean you
you know you played football
obviously you got a hard work to do that
you know you were you're awesome at jiu
jitsu
you're uh you know you you obviously
work out hard so you have
like some aspects in your life that were
real kind of strong
some other aspects of your life we had
some areas right we could improve
that but if you need a little bit a
little bit more on the path
they want to kind of ride a different
wave so yeah it's cool
yeah that that wave is powerful like you
know how they say and there's
there's a bunch of cool quote unquote
cool tag lines where it's like oh
your network is your net worth and like
all this and basically they're all see
that's when somebody asked me like
what's your favorite mantra i started
thinking of all those things and i was
like
you know what i'm not gonna get i'm not
gonna get here and jamie
was like she typed me up she's like hey
jocko everything you say is a mantra and
i'm like
she's like you might not you might not
think it but we all think it's true it's
absolutely true
and the those mantras even the
quote-unquote cheesy ones they all root
the root of
them they're legitimate yeah they're not
untrue yeah and some of them are
absolutely like yes 100 yeah
and these network is your net network
and like
show me your five friends i'll show you
your future or whatever like all that
they're all saying the same thing it's
kind of like your environment
is this big wave that's going to
influence you and you're going to be
riding that thing
and you can fight against it you can
ride with it you can do whatever you
want to do but
brad that's a wave you might want to
pick the right wave if you pick the
right wave you're good but me in this
case
i kinda in a way didn't really pick any
wave at all i'm
essentially rode one way right into
another wave and luckily that
wave was going in the right direction
and it was huge it is huge
so yeah and i was down for it so yeah
man i'm riding it and you know trying to
do the right things for sure and
yes very very beneficial check
uh this next section um i'm gonna jump
through a bunch of these real quick but
this one's called
the person you can control
people are not who you want them to be
kill your idols
sure there are things we can learn from
people but people aren't
going to be what you think they are what
they should be
people even those people you have put on
a pedestal are going to be faulted weak
ego maniacal condescending they are
going to be
lazy entitled short-sighted they will be
they will not be perfect far from it
that's fine
learn from their weaknesses of course
learn from their strengths and mimic and
copy them
in what they do well but equally as
important
learn from their faults see what not to
do
because you can't control other people
you can't make them what you want them
to be
you can't make them who you want them to
be the only person you can control
is you so focus on making yourself who
you want to be
faster stronger smarter more humble less
ego
discipline your body free your mind get
up early and go
get after it and you will become the
person you want to be and you
become that person through one small
decision at a time
yeah as you can see this is a book of
mantras